So let's look at one example of why we may need
synchronization. So let's say we have two threads and what they
are doing is counting occurrences of different letters in a letter.
The first thread, let's call it thread A, is counting in the
first half of the document. So it's going to count occurrences
of each letter in the first half of the document. And the
second thread, let's call that thread B, is counting in the
second half of the document, and then they will put these counts
together somehow. So, the code might look like
this. A thread will load a letter, load from
memory the count for that letter, add one to
that count, and then store the new count back
into memory. While thread A is doing this,
thread B might be doing this. It loads a
letter from its own part of the array. Note
that R1 and R2 are different in these threads.
This is kind of the pointer to where I got
in this part of the array, this is the pointer where
this thread got in its part of the array. So
this thread is doing exactly the same work as this one,
and as long as the letters they're processing are different
this is going to work. This thread is incrementing one part of
the count array, this one is incrementing something else in the
count array. But what if this thread sees letter A. And
this thread, at the same time, sees another letter A in its own part of
the array. Then what happens is they both try to load the same element from the
count array. Let's say the count was 15, so this one will load 15 and this one
will load 15. Now we add one and we get 16, and we do the same
here. Finally, we store 16 to memory, and here
we also store 16 to memory. So now there
were two occurrences of letter A, but the value
in the array ends up being 16, which is
only one more than the original 15. So after
both of these threads are done updating the counter,
the counter should have been 17, so clearly this
is incorrect behavior. What we need is really that
this happens and then this happens, or the other way
around, but these should not be happening
simultaneously because then we can get the incorrect
result. If for example, this happens first,
we load, we get 15. Increment store 16.
Now when we load this here, cache coherence ensures that we load 16
and we end up with 17 here which is a correct result. Similarly if we did this
first it would produce 16 in memory, then we
would load that in increment to 17. So no matter
which one of these happens first we should get the
correct result, but we don't get the correct if they
happen in an interleaved fashion. They should happen one at
a time, I did this and this, or all of
this and then all of this. So these things that
have to execute kind of one at a time are
called atomic or critical sections. So we have one
critical section here and another one here. They can actually
be the same code, it's just that both threads are
currently in the same piece of code. But as you
can see, if we have a section that should behave
as a critical session, meaning, we do this without interference
from any other thread. If we just let it happen,
it's not going to be done correctly. So what we need
is synchronization. We need additional code that ensures that only
one thread gets to do this at any given time.